e
vous allez le voir dans le
reportage de sa force de
personnel administratif tout
régler ce problème.
- Chaque jour dans cet hôpital,
c'est le même problème :
l'afflux de patients quid'accèsn
de famille.
Ici, une dame âgée
attend depuis des heures
avec son conjoint.
des mains pour ne pas venir ici.
J'ai un médecin de famille :
ça aurait pris trois semaines
- "Mon médecin est partiit cet .
Partout au Québec, c'est
un problème grandissant et
c'est en partie pourquoi ici,
a augmenté depuis un an
et pourquoi, malgré l'accalmie
sur le front COVID,
la situa
Dr ERIC LALONDE, Hôpital
du Sacré-Coeur-de-Montréal
- Là, on est revenus à à
des volumes un peu plus élevés.
- Et c'est encore plus compliqué
pour les cas lourds qui doivent
- Nous, on a une capacité
de 46 civières; on est
à 62 patients sur civière.taux
d'occupation des civières
dépasse les 130 % : il faut
encore placer des patients corr.
Normalement, ces gens-là
seraient sur une civière
- Exactement. Ça fait que
je ne connais pas le statut
spécifique de chaque personne;
des gens qui sont en attente
d'hospitalisation à l'étage.
- Si les civières de l'urgence
débordent, c'est parce que
ne peuvent recevoir les patients
qui le nécessitent, comme ic
en pneumologie.
Dr SAMER GEORGES, pneumologue
- Environ 22 patients
hospitalisés en pn
En commençant la semaine,
je vous dirais qu'on était...
qui étaient en attente de sortie
d'hôpifert vers
un autre centre pour la suite
de leur prise en charge,
- C'est vraiment le nerf
de la guerre : troerre : troerre
l'hébergement pour les patients
âgés ou encore des soins
GENEVIÈVE ÉMOND, CIUSSS
du Nord-du Nord-du Nord-du Nordl
- On va transférer ça à qui de
droit pour accélérer le retos p?
- Le défi est crucial,
tellement que même le PDG
de l'établissement assiste
Le CIUSSS vient même d'ajouter
une équipe entièrement consacrée
à ce problème.
sa région, ça noust
un lit, mais, en même temps,
d'instabilité.
- En attendant une solution,aina
force etie des aînés
et on réussit à offrir un séjour
qui augmente parto
dans l'établissement.
On respecte très bien
ma disponibilité, et puis non,
ça regarde bien.
de l'urgence, le tempssupplémese
omniprésent.
- Salut!- Ça te tente-tu de faie
un petit TS ce soir?
- Cette urgence, cnt grâce
au dévouement du personnel.
On se demande combien de temps
ça pourra durer.
Ici Davanada, Mon